[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and welcome
to the Google Cloud Platform
Podcast.
I'm Francesc Campoy, a developer
advocate for the Google Cloud
Platform, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hi.
I'm Mark Mandel.
I'm also a developer advocate
of the Google Cloud Platform.
It's great to be here today.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
great to be with you today.
So yeah, what is this
that we're doing today?
What is a Google Cloud
Platform podcast?
MARK MANDEL:
Apparently we're doing
a podcast talking about
Google Cloud Platform, which
I think is pretty awesome.
I'm really excited
about this project.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, me too.
I'm very excited.
Just to give an idea about
what people should expect
during these
episodes, let's talk
a little bit, before we
start with any content
that we're going to
be covering today,
what is the normal architecture,
the normal layout of--
MARK MANDEL: Of
what we're doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --a podcast.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So, all right.
So first, we want to start
with what we're calling
the Cool Thing of the Week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: It's
gonna be great.
So basically any sort of
really interesting projects,
maybe open source, maybe a new
launch, maybe a tip or trick,
something that we think is
going to be saving people time
when they work on
Google Cloud Platform.
We want to share it
with the audience,
and we want this to be really
like sort of participatory.
If you've got
something out there,
we're happy to fill
in the details,
but if you're like man, check
out this project, it's awesome,
or I did this great thing and
it saved me a heap of time,
please send it through to us.
We really want to hear about it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And by the way, if you want
to get in contact with us
to share any of those
cool things of the week,
we have many ways
of contacting us.
The most important
one is our webpage,
which is gcppodcast.com.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Then I
think we also have an email?
MARK MANDEL:
Hello@gcppodcast.com.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's easy.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And then we are
also on Twitter as GCPpodcast.
On Reddit, we have the
subreddit GCPpodcast.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And then you
can also find us on Google+
by searching GCP Podcast.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
If you search for Google
Cloud Platform Podcast,
we'll show up.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
That's why I prefer to say GCP.
Much easier to say.
So yeah, we're going to have
that part at the beginning
of the episodes.
They're going to be
very participative.
So we're waiting
for your proposals.
And then at the end
of the episodes,
we will finish with
something quite similar.
But rather than saying
something that is cool,
it's going to be the
question of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Really looking forward
to this as well.
Really interested to see
what questions people are
going to send us through.
I think it's going to
be a great resource,
and it's always fun--
you know, at events,
we get great
questions, so we'd love
to share the answers that
we can find with people.
I think that's going
to be lots of fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I'm actually very
excited about this part
just because most of the
questions that we will get,
hopefully we will not
know the answer directly.
MARK MANDEL: Have
to go find it out.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
it's going to be things
that we're going
to have to find out
with other Google engineers,
product managers, and so on.
And after that, we're
going to learn a lot.
So I'm pretty
excited about that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So--
MARK MANDEL: What's coming
between the question
of the week and the cool
thing of the week as well?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that's a little section
we call the main content.
So we're going to
be covering-- we're
going to be doing
many different things.
The idea is that
we're going to have,
like, deep dives on
some specific topic,
like we might not be
talking about it now,
but like what is Datastore,
or SQL versus MySQL,
like SQL versus NoSQL,
things like that.
But also, we want to
cover other topics.
So we're going to be
interviewing other product
managers, engineers, people
that are cool and interesting
in general.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I think also customer projects.
So if there's people out there
using Google Cloud Platform
and you'd love to come on
the podcast, reach out to us.
We totally want to speak to you.
Be great to have you on air.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, it'd be awesome.
MARK MANDEL: And
find out, you know,
what people out there
in the wild are doing.
I mean, that's really the
interesting stuff, too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Yeah, so basically
we're pretty open.
We're going to be talking
about things that we
think are cool, basically.
That's pretty much it.
So, OK.
So what are we going to be
talking about today, then?
MARK MANDEL: OK, so Cool
Thing of the Week, I think,
is pretty straightforward--
we have a podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, that's cool.
MARK MANDEL: That's pretty cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
pretty cool indeed.
And, so yeah.
What about the main content?
MARK MANDEL: So we built
the podcast for Google Cloud
Platform, strangely enough,
on Google Cloud Platform.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's true.
MARK MANDEL: So
why don't we have
a chat about what
we did to build that
and sort of let people
know how they could even
build their own podcasts on
top of Google Cloud Platform,
if that's something
they want to do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
sounds like a good idea.
And actually, just to give
a little bit of context
about how this idea came to be.
So some months ago, I
was chatting with Mark
about the idea of
having a podcast,
and we basically
planned everything out.
We decided everything
that had to be done.
And then, I went on
a month of traveling,
and Mark implemented all this.
So basically, rather than
us explaining how we did it,
it's going to be more like
me asking Mark how he did it.
And I hope I will be learning
some stuff from that today.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
OK.
We can do that.
That sounds great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So first, what is a podcast?
Like, what are the
pieces in a podcast?
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So podcast-- well obviously,
if you're listening to this,
you have some familiarity
with podcasts.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Indeed.
MARK MANDEL: It's
an audio recording
where we talk about stuff, and
we do it on a regular basis.
This is planning
on being weekly,
which is going to be great.
So to actually have a podcast,
we need audio files, generally
mp3 files.
We need to store them somewhere.
We need some sort of
website that sort of shows
what we're talking
about with some content,
very much like a blog.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Show notes and all that.
MARK MANDEL: All that
sort of fun stuff.
And the other big
piece-- well actually,
I have to step back a bit.
We'll need some analytics.
That's really important for us.
We work at Google.
Data is very important.
So we need to be
able to see who's
doing what on the website, and
downloads, things like that.
And finally, we
need an RSS feed.
That's really important
for podcasting.
It's an XML feed that basically
says here are our episodes,
so people can subscribe to it.
They know what episodes
are coming out now,
and then they know when
new episodes come out,
which is pretty cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I see.
So basically, we have to host
some information, both files
and XML.
Then we have to have some
way of distributing it.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And then we want
to measure how
successful we are.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's it.
Cool.
OK, so how do we
store that data?
Where is that data stored?
How do we serve all of that?
MARK MANDEL: We do magic stuff.
OK, so the mp3 files themselves,
the easy answer for that
was Google Cloud Storage.
So that's our platform
for storing binary files.
It's really cool, and
it's very easy to use.
You can create a bucket,
you upload a file.
Generally, I do it
through the web interface,
because it's really simple.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
You can literally drag and drop
files, which is pretty nice.
MARK MANDEL: Which is nice.
And Google Cloud Storage has
edge caching, or edge caching,
because I have an
Australian accent.
And so depending on where you
are in the world, it makes sure
the files are redundantly
stored close to you
so you've got
really low latency.
So it's really awesome.
And so it's-- yeah, very simple.
We just were like, OK, that's
quite clearly where those go.
And it makes life
very, very simple.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And that's actually something
that for a lot of people
is really important, the fact
that when you put something
on Google Cloud Storage, it
might feel like you're storing
it in a disk, and that's it.
But actually, you're not.
You're storing it
everywhere in the world.
So depending on where
people are accessing it,
it's going to be
edge cached anywhere.
So that means that if--
MARK MANDEL: Super
fast downloads.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
If you're listening to
this podcast from Australia
or from Japan or
from Barcelona, you
will get the same experience,
a very fast experience of it
starts downloading
very, very quick.
MARK MANDEL: It's
super, super important.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
But then there's
also the fact that
we don't want people
to listen to the next
episodes of the podcast,
so we can also upload
stuff and then keep
it private for a little bit--
MARK MANDEL: That's true.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
our way of-- what we call
ACLs, or access control lists.
MARK MANDEL: I
believe that's right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So basically that way we can
say, OK, the episode is ready.
We're going to share it
only with people that we
want their views and so on.
So it's--
MARK MANDEL: It's
pretty powerful.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very easy
to use, but very powerful.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yeah And for our podcast,
it's very easy for us
to just go this is all
public f go forth, be happy.
And very, very simple.
Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So, OK, so now we
have those files.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
just the audio, right?
What about the rest?
What about all the
content, the show notes?
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So what we did for that
was a couple of very
interesting things, I think.
So we went with a
static site generator
for the website, a
project called Hugo.
We did that for a
number of reasons,
mainly because
it's written in Go,
and Francesc likes Go a lot.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yay.
MARK MANDEL: So it is actually
a really nice static site
generator.
So we built the
website with that.
And we could extend it to do
all this stuff for podcasting,
and it worked
really, really well.
So once we had all those static
files that Hugo generates,
we needed somewhere
to host that.
So, that makes sense.
We ended-- we actually had
a few options with that.
We ended up actually
going with hosting stuff--
hosting our static
files on App Engine
itself, which is a little bit
maybe controversial, which
is interesting.
But we did it for, I think, a
few good reasons, one of which
is App Engine gives us really
easy access to HTTPS support.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So you can bundle
it up, stick it on App Engine,
put it up in the
cloud, magic cloud.
It still has edge caching, much
like Google Cloud Storage--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, true.
MARK MANDEL: --which
is really nice.
We can also upload
multiple versions
that can be served at the
same time on different URLs.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That's something that I
really like, the fact that you
can do-- not beta testing.
I forgot.
MARK MANDEL: A/B testing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: A/B
testing, that's it.
So yeah, you can do A/B testing.
And see what [INAUDIBLE]
version is more performant,
things like that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And it's great, too.
Like I can make a
podcast episode,
put it up on a different URL,
send it to Francesc and say,
hey, does this
look right to you?
He's like yeah, sweet.
I hit a button in
the dashboard, it
switches it out
with no downtime,
which is really nice, too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that's very nice.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: And the other
reason we went with App Engine
is because we can also
do dynamic content.
So maybe I should actually
step back a little bit
and talk a little bit
about what App Engine is,
for those people who don't know.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That sounds
like a very good idea indeed.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So App Engine is
one of our-- well,
is our primary Platform
as a Service offerings.
So what that really means
is we kind of say, hey,
you need to write
your code this way.
We're going to kind
of dictate it to you
and, as long as you're happy
to do that, then that means
we can do stuff like
really fast scaling,
we can provide you with a
whole bunch of services out
of the box, deployment
is really easy,
because we're able
to sort of adjust
based on those constraints
we put upon you.
And yeah, as long as that fits
with you, it's pretty cool.
So I mean, there's
a lot of customers
we have that use App
Engine and like the model,
because they can just be
like, oh, I don't really
care how much traffic I
get, because App Engine is
going to handle it for
me, and that's awesome.
So it's pretty cool.
I mean, it supports Go,
it supports PHP, Java,
and Python--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: --out of the box.
And so those are some
pretty decent languages
that have some
pretty decent, like,
penetration into the community.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
The thing that I really
like about App Engine is
that basically what you do is
you just give us your code.
And there's some restrictions on
what kind of code you can run,
but you basically
just give us your code
and, if it matches
our restrictions,
then we just run it for
you, whatever happens.
MARK MANDEL: And
the restrictions
are pretty, like, reasonable.
I mean, it's for
web stuff, right?
So it's no requests
over 60 seconds.
Well, you probably shouldn't
be doing that anyway.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And there's things like
you cannot run C++,
things like that.
But if you want to do
that, we have other--
MARK MANDEL: We have other
stuff for that sort of thing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, we
have other places to run it.
And yeah, there's-- some of
the customers that run this,
it's actually pretty impressive,
because you think like, oh,
yeah, it's something
that's going to scale.
But can I actually trust it?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There's
Rovio that uses it.
There's Khan Academy
that uses it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
There's Snapchat that--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Snapchat is huge.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It's huge.
And it supports-- like, it's
just running on App Engine,
and it runs very well.
MARK MANDEL: We do something
like 10 times the traffic
of Wikipedia, looking at some
of the slides we've had, like--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, on App
Engine and in general, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It's pretty impressive.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's quite
a decent amount of traffic.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And for our needs here for
our podcast, I mean, we fit.
We fit the mold really well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Clearly.
MARK MANDEL: So we can serve
static content through it
no problem, which is great.
But yeah, we've also
got some Go code
that we're using to
do our analytics.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: Which is
the other side of things.
So what we do is
we basically have
just a very simple
redirect in our code
to say where we're
downloading our podcast from.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
MARK MANDEL: And what that
does is, on that redirect,
the HTTP request
comes in, we do a 503,
it redirects to--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cloud Storage?
MARK MANDEL: Cloud
Storage. [INAUDIBLE]
my brain just fell over.
Yeah, so it sends off a request
to Google Analytics using
a little Go library we
have, basically saying hey,
here's an event of
a podcast download,
and here's the podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: So we're able to
leverage Google Cloud-- Google
Analytics and use
all its tooling,
and basically be able to
still use all the code on App
Engine at the same time.
So we can have
dynamic code running,
we can have static
content at the same time,
deployment's really easy--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's pretty sweet.
It's actually really nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's very nice.
So for the people that
are curious about it,
what's the library that
you're using for Go Analytics?
MARK MANDEL: It's
Go Ogle Analytics,
and it'll be in the show notes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's a great name.
MARK MANDEL: It's a great name.
I think the package
name is actually GA.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Ah, OK.
MARK MANDEL: When it
actually gets used.
It's actually a
really nice library.
It uses Google Analytics
measurement API.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: You
can send any data.
I'm sure we'll get more
sophisticated with it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
I'll give it a try.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It's pretty nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
OK.
So now we've seen how
to store our data,
both files like audio
files and everything else,
all the HTML, CSS,
images and so on.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We've
seen how we manage--
how we measure our success.
But how do we
cause that success?
How do we know how to make
people realize that there's
a new episode up there?
MARK MANDEL: So
the big thing here
is what's called,
like, an RSS feed.
I think it stands for
Really Simple Syndication.
And there's a few
other versions.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Good.
MARK MANDEL: It's
essentially an XML feed.
If anyone's been
involved with blogging,
they've probably seen this
in one way or another.
It's an XML format
that says hey,
I just wrote a new blog post
or a new episode of something.
So when podcasting
came around, it sort of
got extended a little bit.
So not only is it like, hey,
I just put out a blog post,
it's like, hey, I
put out a blog post,
and it's got this
audio attached to it.
And there are some
extensions for iTunes
and some extensions
for other things
like that to be able
to put some metadata
around that audio file.
But it becomes a really
simple way of letting everyone
know who's subscribing,
hey, there's a new podcast,
you might want to listen
to it, it's kind of cool,
and come on down.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's nice.
And so once we have that RSS
feed that we're publishing,
how will people find it?
Like they can go to
GCPpodcast.com, sure.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And there's a link
directly there.
So you could just
go to GCPpodcast.
If your podcast-- if
you've got a podcast app
or anything like that, you
can just point at the XML feed
quite easily.
It'll be on iTunes.
We'll probably get it on
Stitcher at some point soon.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
Very nice.
MARK MANDEL: I'm sure if-- yeah.
It should be pretty
easy to get on board.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So the last part is,
OK, sure, so now we
have a static content--
a static site.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What if
people want to comment on it?
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So what we decided
to do was basically
use some existing communities.
So as we said before, if
people want to contact us,
they can do it on Reddit and
they can do it on Google+.
So we're going to put a
post there for every episode
and just say, hey, if
you want to add comments,
please come talk to us here.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: It makes
life really simple,
and we can take advantage
of those communities.
So I think that's going to
hopefully work quite well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm actually
very excited, especially
about Reddit.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
think that Reddit
is a very active community,
and hopefully we're
going to get nice conversations
going on in there.
MARK MANDEL: I haven't
participated that much
in Reddit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, really?
MARK MANDEL: I
have to be honest.
No.
But yeah, I'm always
open to new things,
so that sounds like fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I like it.
I think it's going to be fun.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I think that, with that,
we kind of finished how
to run a podcast on the cloud.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I think so.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That was pretty nice.
Cool.
That was pretty easy.
MARK MANDEL: That was-- yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So we said that we had the
cool thing of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Then
the main content.
So now we're going for
the third part, which
is the question of the week.
Do you happen to have one?
MARK MANDEL: I happen to
have a question of the week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: I was at an
event a little while ago.
It was a sports-themed event.
And so this question
came up where
we were talking about-- we had a
potential customer asking about
whether we were HIPAA-compliant.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What is that?
MARK MANDEL: So I'm not
going to try and explain it
to the degree of being a
lawyer, but essentially
if you're doing
health-type things,
then you might need this sort
of governmental compliance
to be able to be like,
yes, I can run legally.
This seems really, really good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK, so the
H in HIPAA stands for health
somehow.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: That's
H-I-P-A-A compliant.
And the nice answer to that
question is actually yes,
we are HIPAA-compliant.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: If you're
interested in our HIPAA
compliance or any
other compliance,
we actually have a page
under cloud.google.com
/security/compliance, where we
talk about all our compliance
needs.
We do business associate
agreements, all that sort
of fun stuff, as well.
So generally speaking, if you
need that sort of compliance,
you generally know you need
that sort of compliance.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: If you do need
that sort of compliance
and you don't know, you'll
find out pretty quickly.
But yeah, I mean, thankfully
it was a really easy question
to answer when we got asked.
So yeah, I mean-- and then also
in that URL you can check out
our security stuff as well.
There's a lot of actually
really interesting--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, there's a lot
of really interesting
information out there.
Great.
So you said that the question
of the week for this week
came from an event.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
What else are you
going to be doing
regarding to events?
What are you doing next?
MARK MANDEL: I've got a
few things on my plate.
The thing probably locked
in the most I'll mention
is I will be at
Clojure/conj in November.
I do like my
functional programming,
so I'm really
excited about that.
I'll be talking about
wrapping Clojure developer
tools in containers.
Where are you going to be
in the next little while?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Gonna be at
many, many places, actually.
Yeah, in November I'm
going to go to OreDev.
I'm not really sure I
pronounced it correctly.
It's the weird O, like Swedish
O, so I'm not really sure.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And it's in Malmo.
It's going to be a
very nice conference.
I'm going to be talking
about Go and Go on the cloud.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And then I'm going
to go to dotGo,
which is in Paris.
MARK MANDEL: Of course you are.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Go
conference again.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And that's
going to be really fun.
I still don't know what I'm
going to be talking about,
but I think it's
going to be quite fun.
I might talk about
functional programming in Go.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, we
should talk about that.
That would be fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that's gonna be scary.
And then we're going to have
a lot of people from our team,
from Google Cloud Platform
advocacy team at Devoxx
in Antwerp in Belgium.
MARK MANDEL: That
should be lots of fun.
It's a shame I'm
missing that, actually.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We're gonna
be running a couple workshops.
We're going to be there.
So if you're going to be
somewhere around there,
feel free to come say hi.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Brilliant.
OK.
Well, that sounds great.
Well, if you aren't going
to be at those events,
please feel free to
send us an email,
reach out to us on Twitter,
reach out to us on Reddit.
We'd love to talk to you.
Community interaction
is awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: We're
super looking forward
to that side of everything.
Let's remind people
where they can reach us.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
So for the webpage,
it's gcppodcast.com.
MARK MANDEL: Lovely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: For the email,
it's hello@gcppodcast.com.
For the Twitter handle,
it's GCPpodcast.com.
MARK MANDEL: Actually,
it's just GCPpodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
MARK MANDEL: You
repeated a little.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I got too excited.
For the subreddit,
it's GCPpodcast.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And then
you can find us on Google+
searching for Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
OK, well, I think that
probably wraps us up there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
MARK MANDEL: Well, thank you
very much for joining me,
Francesc.
I look forward to doing
many of these with you soon.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Thank you, and
see you next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]